We're asked to graph the
solution set for this system.
So we have two inequalities
here, so this is a system of
inequalities, and we know how
to graph them independently.
And so when you graph the
system, you want to find the
set of coordinates in the
coordinate plane that satisfy
both of these inequalities.
So we essentially want to
find out where these two
inequalities overlap.
So let's graph this first
one over here.
I'll rewrite it in magenta.
y is greater than x minus 8.
So the way to think about this,
let's think about y is
equal x minus 8, but we're going
to be greater than that,
so we're going to draw
a dotted line at y is
equal x minus 8.
So if you think about x minus 8,
the y-intercept is negative
8, so it's one, two, three,
four, five, six, seven, eight.
That is negative
8 right there.
This, of course,
is the y-axis.
That is the x-axis.
And the graph of y equals
x minus 8 has
a slope of 1, right?
There's 1 times this
x right here.
So every time you move in the
positive x-direction, you move
1 in the positive y-direction.
If you move 2, you get 2 in
the positive y-direction.
If you moved 3, you would
go up 3 in the positive
y-direction.
And likewise, if you went in
the negative x-direction.
You'd also go in the negative
y-direction by 1.
So this line, if you said y is
equal to x minus 8, it would
be a line just like that.
But since we're not going to
include it in this set, we
have to be greater
than that line.
I'll do a dotted line here.
Let me do my best to draw
a dotted line, which is
surprisingly easier to draw
that a non-dotted line.
So that is essentially a dotted
line version of y is
equal to x minus 8.
But we're going to be
greater than that.
So for any x, x minus 8 is going
to be on that line, but
the y is going to be all the
values greater than that.
So you pick any x, this is x
minus 8, the y-value is going
to be all the y's greater
than that for that x.
So the solution set for y is
greater than x minus 8 is all
of the area above this line
and it doesn't include it.
And that's why I put a
dotted line there.
So let me do that in
a lighter color.
So literally, all of this area
up here is the solution set
for this first inequality.
Now, let's do the second
inequality.
I'll do it in another
dark color.
We have y is less than 5 minus
x, or we could write that as
negative x plus 5, so it looks
a little bit more like our
slope-intercept form.
Now, if we were just to graph y
is equal to negative x plus
5, it would look like this.
We would go in the positive
y-direction one, two, three,
four, five.
That is the y-intercept
right there.
And it has a slope
of negative 1.
So if we move 1 in the
x-direction, we move down 1.
It we move 3 in the x-direction,
we're going to
move down 3.
If we move back 3 in the
x-direction, we're
going to move up 3.
So this line is going
to look like this.
And I'm to do it in a dotted
line because we're not
including it.
It's not less than or equal.
It's just strictly less than, so
it won't include the line.
So it's going to look
something like this.
I'll try my best to draw it
as neatly as possible.
I think that is a
respectable job.
This is the dotted line version
of y is equal to
negative x plus 5.
It's dotted because we're
not including it.
Now, for any x, you pick an x,
let's say x is equal to one,
negative x plus 5 is going
to get on to that line.
But for that x, we only care
about the y's that are less
than that value.
So it's going to be all the
values below this line.
So if you look at the solution
set for this second
inequality, it will
look like this.
I'll do it in this
light blue color.
It will be all of the area
below this blue line.
Now, what we care about is the
set of coordinates that
satisfy both of these
inequalities.
Now, in order to satisfy both
inequalities, it has to be the
overlap of the solution sets.
And the overlap of the solution
sets, where the blue
is overlapping with the yellow
in this case, is everything
that is above this line and
everything that's below that
line, so it's all of
this area here.
So let me color that in
a little bit bolder.
So it's all of this below
the blue line and
above the red line.
This is the overlap.
All of this area, all of that
area right there is the
solution set for this system.
And you can verify it.
Pick a random point in this
area and see it'll satisfy
both points.
And a really easy one is x is
equal to 0, y is equal to 0.
That's part of our
solution set.
Let's try it out.
If y is 0, 0 is greater
than 0 minus 8.
That's true.
0 is greater than negative 8.
If you do the second equation,
0 is less than 5 minus 0.
That's true.
0 is less than 5.
And you could try that
with any points here.
This orange area is
our solution set.